this ten-year-old from afghanistan's
eastern province of pakhtiya was shot on
saturday it took his family eight hours
to reach emergency hospital in central
kabul by then he was in bad shape
this is the first intensive care unit in
afghanistan doctors say they witnessed a
surge in patients after the taliban took
over kabul on sunday they said most were
the victims of armed clashes criminals
and chaos at the
a airport situation that
unfortunately causes many many injured
people by bullets and by shields and so
on
for two days the hospital was
overflowing they added extra beds all
admissions were from gunshot wounds
the hospital says it has received about
20 patients from kabul international
airport since monday
four have died and the rest are being
treated for gunshot wounds after the
taliban and u.s forces tried to disperse
crowds that breached the perimeter
we received the patients from around
back of the airport of afghanistan that
most of most of them that we receive as
bullet injury to the through the chest
and head
this hospital is run by emergency ngo an
international humanitarian organization
with the taliban in charge they say
their operations have continued on
uninterrupted they say the minister of
health has remained the same and
fighters have introduced themselves
i have to say so far our 20 years that
we are in the country
we always we able to work and everybody
respect us nobody forces us to do
nothing that was not just to take care
of the patient
mabu brahman is 12 years old when the
taliban took over his province of host
on sunday he ran out to meet them he was
hit by a government water another child
died and he is now paralyzed
we have 18 or 19 years of war and in the
last 10 minutes he was injured at least
he is alive and he will be okay
i can suffer and tolerate this if there
is peace
the war may be over but in afghanistan
the healing will take a long time
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul